[Music]
jim is with us jim's in knoxville hi jim
welcome to the ramsey show
hey how are you doing dave great man
what's up
all right i'll keep it kind of short and
to the point
been a listener for a while and
i've heard a lot of calls relating to
careers and things like that
but i've not been one on this situation
that i'm in
about 10 years ago
due to
some substances
and partying i became a felon and
to keep it very short and concise
i can't stand the job i'm at
and out of the last
50 applications that i've put in every
one of them has for a job every one of
them has come back as a no so i was
hoping maybe you
as a business owner and a leader could
give me some advice on that
yeah you're always going to get a no on
applications you've got to get your foot
in the door with somebody you know ken
coleman teaches that
um and in his book the proximity
principle
so let me go back
what you have to have is you have to
have a narrative a story to tell that is
the truth
that explains this situation to a
reasonable person
okay
so
you got busted for drugs what happened
yes okay um yeah i got a dui and when
they pulled me over
i didn't have a concealed carry permit
and so i got a charge for that
and the because of that and apparently i
was being stubborn that night i don't
remember to be honest with you um but
how long you've been driving charged
with penalty uh let's say that was
how long have you been dry 2012 october
of 2012 october 2nd okay so you haven't
you haven't done drugs or alcohol since
that's correct okay
and uh you were how old at the time
i just turned 21.
okay
and so you're 30 right
just turned 31 a few weeks ago but yeah
okay
so um
the way i would do this is just to bring
this up fairly early in the process so
you got a friend that works over at so
and so and they'll get you in to see the
boss for an interview you go in and sit
down and go listen i'd love to work here
but i won't be really upfront with you
way back in my 20s 10 years ago i was
partying i've been dry for 10 years but
i got busted and uh so i've got a felony
and if that if that's a deal killer
because of 10 something 10 years ago in
my past i just want you to know up front
and if you said that to me in an
interview i would say well let's just
keep talking i appreciate you bringing
it up but i want to know more about you
and i'm not going to rule you out based
on that
if you're a child molester 16 months ago
you're out of here i don't want to talk
to you anymore that's me okay but a rake
but most of us did something in our 20s
we're not proud of and hope nobody finds
out about in your case everybody found
out about it
that's correct
yeah and the other thing i i i love the
the advice you gave dave of if you have
the conversation explaining the context
around it you don't tell them your life
story but giving some context because
when people hear the word felon they can
jump to conclusions and that title
encompasses a lot of stuff even as you
told us like when you were telling your
story you said well i did some drugs and
i just turned 21 i was like oh
my my my initial thought was oh okay
well that's not that bad you know i mean
it's like it was 10 years ago it was 10
years ago and so i just think that
people will
hear you out when you give context
around that just like you said dave
you'd say well but if you're in a pile
of a thousand resumes and they're trying
to narrow it down the first thing
they're gonna do is just call out the
felons yeah yeah they're not even
they're trying to get down to one or two
to interview okay but you've got to get
in the door with someone that you know
which by the way is what we teach people
that don't have this situation still the
same exact information king coleman says
you have to get in the door with someone
you know let me give you an example okay
if regardless of your uh criminal
background all right we have 30
something thousand applications coming
in to ramsey this year
for 350 jobs
the chances of you getting out of that
stack
period
is obviously statistically very low
unless you've got a friend that works
here or a friend of a friend that works
here that runs down to hr and says hey
at least give this guy a look
and that's that little bit of connection
of who you know and it's not that they
get the person the job because that
never happens here
it's that they get them a look and they
get out of the stack and they'll get you
a look and then you go in and just tell
the truth of this story it's 10 years
ago i've been dry 10 years but when you
look it up you're going to find a felony
for a stupid kid that was doing drugs
back then not done anything like that
since but you're going to find that back
there and you just move on real quick
little narrative and explain it most
people will go okay he's a 21 year old
idiot i mean that's what happened most
of us were right
and so
and they move on but some of them aren't
i mean if you get some kind of corporate
goob
they've got some kind of policy they
can't break but that would not keep you
from getting hired here
so your strategy then jim would be
instead of just applying for any job
that has a position with your skills the
strategy would be let's make a list of
people we know that work at companies
that we might like to work for or make a
list of companies we might like to work
for that we might know someone at and um
and let's let's give him a copy of ken
coleman's new book from paycheck to
purpose absolutely i'm gonna send you
two books and i want you to go to ken's
website and download everything he's got
at kingcoleman.com for free as well the
book is paycheck to purpose it's the
brand new book that came out yesterday
and ken's first book which is what we're
kind of talking about here is the
proximity principle get in proximity of
the things you want to do use someone
you know to get your foot in the door
and we'll send both of those out for you
and get you going so proud of you jim
good job staying dry 10 years man that's
pretty cool that's hard to do and
obviously you've got a couple scars to
prove it so uh you'll get there you'll
get through you'll get this to where
it's further and further and further in
your rear view mirror the beauty of the
rear view mirror is it's a lot smaller
than the windshield
the windshield is your future that's
called grace